et on va aller plus loin dans le grand
débat avec nous ce soir françois
grosdidier bonsoir sénateurs à l'ère de
la moselle
loïc prud'hommes bonsoir bienvenue à
vous député la france insoumise de
gironde vous faites partie du groupe de
députés qui a fait cette proposition de
loi pour une légalisation contrôlée du
cannabis à usage récréatif martin perez
bonsoir et bienvenue médecin journaliste
spécialiste des questions santé et
chroniqueuse à pharma radio et marc
valleur bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
psychiatre au centre marmottan à paris
et spécialiste des pratiques addictives
légaliser le cannabis à usage récréatif
une égalisation contrôle et dites-vous
par l'état loïc prud'hommes ce que vous
proposez en clair c'est de créer un
grand service public public du cannabis
c'est cela a expliqué löw c'est surtout
de sortir aujourd'hui de la situation
qui est factuellement la suivante c'est
qu'il ya 3 9 millions de consommateurs
en france dont 1,2 million de
consommateurs réguliers avec les
problèmes d'addiction que cela pose
derrière et c'est à ça qu'on se propose
de répondre en ayant un encadrement
effectivement qu'il soit par l'état par
la puissance publique par les services
de santé aussi français pour qu'on
arrive à sortir de cette problématique
de santé publique telle qu'elle se
présente aujourd'hui sans avoir un débat
passionné mais plutôt en verlan des
choses avec la tête froide et et au
regard des chiffres des tentatives qui
ont été faites sur corriger ce qui est
aujourd'hui le problème de l'addiction
en france et au regard aussi des
exemples que l'on a aujourd'hui sur le
territoire européen sur des précédentes
expériences on a du recul on y reviendra
plus tard mais qui montre qui a une voix
pour cette dépénalisation sur le
principe françois grosdidier 6 et
encadrée par l'état
je trouve absolument extraordinaire
l'argument qui est utilisée qui consiste
à dire parce qu'on peut pas empêcher
phénomène on va légaliser
on n'a jamais pu empêcher complètement
toutes les violations le des interdits
on continue à voler on continue à
incendier on continue à faire de la bo
de la femme fiscale c'est pas pour ça
qu'on va légaliser la fraude fiscale bon
un problème c'est à voir si c'est plutôt
bien ou plutôt mal à la fois pour ceux
qui consomment et pour la société
réponse assez unanimes c'est que c'est
plutôt mal et qu'il faut plutôt
dissuader alors comme l'alcool et le
tabac mais qui étaient installés dans
notre culture et qu'on essaie de sortie
on va pas tomber de stupide y est de
sortir de stupidité comme l'alcool et le
tabac pour replonger dans cinq ans
voulait lui cette note récente du
conseil d'analysé économique a dressé un
constat terrible sur la politique de
répression de la france le site la
france est l'un des pays les plus
répressifs en matière de lutte contre le
cannabis elle y consacre beaucoup
d'argent et pourtant elle fait figure de
champion mais les années mais c'est pas
vrai y'a pas de mal
y'a pas de répression je veux dire
pourquoi il y en a pas parce que les
trafics sont réprimées mais la
consommation ne l'est pas il n'y a aucun
parquet aujourd'hui qui est poursuivi
pour consommation
donc c'est pour ça que le pouvoir actuel
et les jeunes soutiens sur ce point veut
faire une amende forfaitaire pour
qu'effectivement il ya une sanction
effective il y en a pour dépassement de
vitesse ou pour mauvais stationnement il
y en a pas pour vous monsieur kabiné
répression c'est pas vrai on n'a fait
aucune répression et par ailleurs on ne
fait pas de prévention parce qu'avec ce
discours sur l égalisation en fait alors
qu'on condition qu'on fait du matraquage
qui justifie sur l'alcool et sur le
tabac eh bien les pouvoirs publics de
souligne pas assez la nocivité du cada
n'arrive à la santé pour la réussite
scolaire
oui je pense qu'il fait tant qu'il ya un
débat un peu plus serein et que on se
borne pas aux grands principes des pour
et des contres avec dédé d'horribles
laxiste qui serait pour la légalisation
et des gens qui fait pour montrer les
muscles et montrer qu'on est rude et
qu'il faut maintenir l'interdît non la
pénalisation de l' usage simple et 10 en
france depuis 1970 c'est la législation
la plus dure d'europe en matière d'usagé
de drogue et la france a le record
d'europe de la consommation de cannabis
ya 17 millions d' expérimentateurs de
cannabis à 17 millions de personnes qui
disent oui on a fumé du cannabis
ses 17 millions de personnes que la loi
actuelle permettrait de mettre un an en
prison
cette loi est absurde je travaille avec
toxic je travaille avec des toxicomanes
depuis 1974
tout le monde à peu près chez les
spécialistes pensent depuis cette époque
que cette loi est beaucoup trop dur
qu'il faut la changer
c'est depuis 1974 et ça ne change
toujours pas en 2010 on a légalisé on a
libéralisé même le jeu en ligne
ça aurait pu être l'occasion de mettre
sur la table les différents produits
d'éditeurs de voir quel niveau de
régulation voulait pour eux le cas du
cannabis est exemplaire c'est
probablement dans les substance
interdite celle qui a le moins dans le
faisons fait un rapport avec le
professeur barnard rock en 1997 sur la
dangerosité des drogues et le cannabis
venait bien en dessous de l'alcool bien
en dessous du tabac est évidemment en
dessous leur et vous n'êtes pas seul à
le penser on a vu cet appel de l'ops
martin perez un appel de 70 médecins
économistes et élus qui sont pour une
légalisation contrôlée des élus des
économistes des médecins est ce que ça
que je pense qu'il a commencé à tourner
et réfléchie de personnes qui rend
réfléchissant il s'agit pas d'être
agressif ou d'un de s'énerver c'est un
débat qui est intéressant et qui revient
sur la table depuis des années moi j'ai
travaillé en tant que journaliste
longtemps dans beaucoup de médias
et effectivement ce débat en revient de
manière récurrente dans le dangereux
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre l'intérêt
de légaliser le cannabis
d'abord parce que le cannabis c'est une
substance toxique et on le sait on en
reparlera peut-être
il ya comme des effets psychiatriques
piano déclaré aujourd'hui à délayer des
effets psychiatriques qui sont très
clairement établi pendant longtemps
savait pas si le risque de schizophrénie
étaient liées au cannabis ou simplement
les gens qui avaient déjà des troubles
psychotiques s'automédiquer que cannabis
aujourd'hui il ya clairement des
éléments qui permettent de dire que le
canada peut être un déclencheur ça peut
être un déclencheur chez des gens qui
sont prédisposés même génétiquement
voyez c'est assez sophistiqué c'est
dangereux aussi parce que c'est on sait
très bien que les gens qui fument
beaucoup de joie et les jeunes en
particulier souffrent de
désinvestissement que scolaire massif et
que ça pousse des vrais problèmes et que
c'est très dur de le remettre dans le
circuit scolaire c'est un facteur
accidentogène
aujourd'hui plusieurs plus quand on
regarde les accidents de la route on se
rend compte d'autoriser un consommé du
cannabis
trop les voitures que tu es un enfant
visiblement il était sous l'emprise du
cannabis voilà il ya aussi c'est aussi
toxique pour les poumons alors l'autre
l'autre argument qui ont fait que je
suis pas tellement favorable à la
légalisation du cannabis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est adolescent
et tous de tout temps d'ailleurs c'est
parce que aujourd'hui on a besoin de
transgresser on a besoin de progresser
quelque chose si on légalise aujourd'hui
l'élève mandat transgresse qu'est ce
qu'on va transgresser c'est une règle
est immuable nous laisse intéressante à
vivre à l'économie parallèle à ce
qu'elle soit le transfert sur les
drogues dures
alors ça sur le plan psychologique c'est
ce que ce soit sur le plan psychologique
que sur le plan sociétal maintenir une
loi pour que les gens à transgressera
mon avis c'est un paradoxe ici les
parents interdisent quelque chose pour
que les enfants lui face à mon avis et
des parents un peu vicieux le jeu
l'autre chose dangereuse gestion que
pense j'espère que dans le projet de loi
qui a été déposé il ne s'agit pas de
permettre la consommation aux mineurs
comme pour le jeu le après 18 ans le jeu
des mineurs est interdite ça veut dire
que la vente du jeu est interdite aux
mineurs que de même que la vente
d'alcool est interdite aux mineurs
il s'agit d'interdire la vente il s'agit
de ne plus pénaliser l'usm progrès alors
on va avancer parce que c'est toujours
intéressant de voir ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans le monde où vous l'avez un
petit peu évoqué le cannabis à usage
récréatif est déjà légale dans quelques
pays au canada depuis octobre 2018 il
est alors d'ailleurs devenu le premier
pays du g7 à le faire cinq ans avant
c'était l'uruguay huit états américains
l'ont légalisé dont la californie l'état
de washington
plus près de nous chez nos voisins
européens belgique le cannabis reste
illégal mais la possession de cannabis
est dépénalisée depuis 2003 l'allemagne
la république tchèque le danemark ou
encore l'italie ne tolère pas le
cannabis mais les amendes encourues sont
assez légères ce qui est aussi
révélateur
la france fait partie des pays où la
législation est la plus dure d'europe
est ce que ça va changer la position du
gouvernement n'est pas d'aller vers une
légalisation du cannabis est ce que nous
a dit tout à l'heure si bête ndiaye
pourtant écouter ce que disait emmanuel
macron lorsqu'il était candidat c'est
une archive de septembre 2016 écouter
aujourd'hui le cannabis pose un problème
en effet de sécurité de lien avec la
délinquance dans des quartiers
difficiles de financement de réseaux
occultes
et donc on voit bien que la légalisation
du cannabis à des intérêts de ce point
de vue et à une forme d'efficacité et
donc on voit bien que de ce point de vue
il le sujet est ouvert et doit être
considérée quand on regarde ailleurs
l'incapacité qu'ont les magistrats de
régler le problème d'un point de vue
pénal on voit que nous sommes dans un
système très si pauvre des facs on de
l'autre
de l'autre côté j'entends et je suis
aujourd'hui pas en situation parce que
c'est un sujet que je veux travailler
donc je ne suis pas contre oui oui mais
en fait les arguments qu'on à attendre
entendu c'est exactement ça c'est que
tous les arguments que vous avez
développé sont sous l'angle répressif ou
sous l'angle de la morale moi je la
barre assez pragmatique un jouet mais
celle des candidats qui a peut-être
changé d'avis depuis mais je rejoins le
fait que nous on le regarde sous l'angle
sanitaire c'est comment aujourd'hui on
arrive à apporter une réponse sanitaire
c'est pas demain une loi pour que tout
le monde fume du cannabis c'est
justement au contraire pour pouvoir
avoir en main tous les éléments est
l'antidote cela ouvre la voie
les vannes mais non pas du tout parce
que les exemples vous avez pas cité dans
le petit panel mais je pense que le
portugal était un exemple intéressant
qui a fait vraiment une action très très
faim de très significatif sur la
légalisation de l'usagé des drogues et
c'était il ya maintenant presque vingt
ans et on voit que notamment le nombre
de
deux personnes dépendantes a diminué de
moitié donc voilà un vrai résultat je
dire parler c'est pragmatique on a du
recul sur les maladies psychiatriques
est-ce qu'il y en a plus y en a pas plus
bien au contraire c'est en tout cas des
gens du coup comme il ya moins de gens
dépendants déjà on se tire comme une
bonne épine du pied par rapport à ça et
puis du coup la manne aussi de ces deux
financière qui passe du coup du registre
du marché noir parce que c'est un
milliard quand même d'euros cette
économie parallèle vers un marché public
que l'on contrôle permet de faire de la
prévention et de suivre de donner les
moyens de suivre les gens qui seraient
encore dans l'addiction et c'est la
proposition que l'on fait c'est d'avoir
ces centres aussi où on peut suivre ses
consommateurs et si je trouve
extraordinaire de penser que c'est en
autorisant un phénomène qu'on va le
réduire mais c'est les fans non mais
autrement elles reculé autrement on
autoriserait l'alcool au volant
autrement aurait autorisé énorme votre
caricature qu'on a animé non m'attendais
déjà dans le module nommé dans le mode
de raisonnement autorisé un phénomène en
pensant de réduire non l'autorisé celle
encouragée et comment je vais dire moi
mes gamins mais attendez ça c'est pas
bien au moment où précisément la société
relie malaisie mais enfin c'est le
contre messages que vous envoyez à tout
et société attendez je vous ai écoutés
on peut parler successivement ces
messieurs vous parle a chacun notre tour
au sénat c'est comme ça je vais pas
commencer à le faire et donc qu'on dit
pas de bêtise
ici on parle chacun le nom mais remercie
pour moi où aller alors le respecte
l'opinion des autres sans insulter non
plus ouais c'est pour ça que la
proposition de j'ai le droit d'être
contre au sénat on respecte aussi
l'opinion contradictoires de ce qui vous
est très difficile me semble-t-il
affaires et est bien donc je pense qu
autoriser le phénomène c'est précisément
l'encourager deuxièmement contrairement
à ce que vous avez dit il ya un décalage
en france entre une loi la plus
répressive et l'application de la loi
qui est la plus laxiste parce que je le
redis il n'y a aucun parquet qui depuis
des années des années ne poursuit la
consommation est justement le prêt dans
un public dont je ne suis pas un soutien
qui a réfléchi à cette question propose
lui l'amendé forfaitaire c'est à dire la
sanction effective mais juste
proportionnée excessive
il faut que ce soit pénale pour
demain pouvoir aussi ordonné des
injonctions thérapeutiques récidive et c
c'est à dire que c'est effectivement un
outil qui est proportionné ensuite le
faux argument qui consiste à dire on va
dégonfler d'économie parallèle je la
connaissais même pas là j'ai combattu
dans une ville qui était le supermarché
de la drogue dans ma région même
l'hypermarché et bien désolé ceux qui
vivent de ça demain ils vivent pas du
cannabis eh bien s'ils ne sont pas
combattues
ils vont reporter sur les drogues dures
parce que leur chiffre d'affaires loi
n'y arrive tout simplement un déport
d'activité donc non seulement vous
encourager la consommation des drogues
dites douces et qui sont n'est pas pour
la santé pour le lien social e vo pour
rome qui qui peuvent développer des ddd
maladie atteint de schizophrénie mais
met par ailleurs vous ne réglez pas le
problème sous l'angle de la sécurité
d'ordre public à être contredit kong
double elle qui va se déporter sur les
drogues dures et qui on roulera qui
engagera qui encouragera aussi la
consommation de drogues dures c'est pour
ça je pense que votre initiative qui par
de bons sentiments produira le résultat
exactement inverse de celui de celui que
martine s'élève alors je lis juste vous
dire c'est pas un problème de morale on
est tous d'accord pour dire non pas du
tout mais je ne vois vraiment pas où
vous mettez de la morale ni lui ni moi
ni personne ne fait de la morale ici
vous dites que l'autorisation va régler
les deux beaucoup de problèmes il va
simplifier les choses
mais autorisation du tabac depuis les
années 40 ça n'a jamais interdit ces 73
mille morts par an et on a beaucoup de
mal à le combattre
l'autorisation de l'alcool c'est un
problème aussi majeur et je vois pas non
plus en quoi l'autorisation et la
légalisation du cannabis permettra de
régler le problème ça il faudrait comme
le démontre par a plus b
j'ai pas l'impression que dans les pays
où ces légaliser bien aucun problème lié
au cannabis et puis le marché parallèle
on devrait leur tout pour pour lutter
contre les marchés parallèles
il faut il devrait bien sûr autorisé la
cocaïne l'héroïne tout ce qui est
absolument interdit si on veut vraiment
lutter contre les marchés parallèles
en fait ayant nous avons des outils des
outils juridiques judiciaires pour
lutter contre les marchés parallèles des
10 et des outils et donc c'est ça
l'objectif
on ne va pas doit pas être un argument
selon c'est pas un argument celebuzz je
vous dis ce n'est pas dans la morale
marc valleur
je pense que on est dans une discussion
qui est la même qu'à 40 ans et c'est
vraiment dommage
les les conditions ont beaucoup changé
il ya une dizaine d'états américains qui
ont légalisé l'usagé de cannabis le
canada l'a légalisé depuis hanoï
l'uruguay depuis cinq ans il faudrait
qu'on fasse ont pour noms mais il faut
être pragmatique à mon avis le mouvement
est inéluctable et il faut mieux
commencer à réfléchir aux modalités de
la légalisation
on a on a des exemples contradictoire
quand on dit que le laxisme ça en fait
des problèmes en est l'exemple européen
montre exactement le contraire les pays
les plus souples au niveau législatif le
portugal la hollande sont ceux qui ont
le moins de problèmes de consommation et
ça à diminuer les consommations les pays
les plus durs dans le monde en matière
de drogues sont ceux où il ya le plus de
d'usagé de drogue c'est le cas ça a été
le cas délirants pour l'héroïne c'est le
cas des philippines ou en tulle et
toxicomane dans la rue et où les
problèmes de cesse d'augmenter donc dire
que il faut être dur pour qui le
problème c'est faux on sait que c'est
faux je ne mélange pas tout on sait que
c'est fou on sait que par ailleurs et
pour aller dans ce sens le libéralisme
absolu le laxisme absolue et dangereux
aussi
il s'agit pas de mettre du cannabis avec
de la publicité avec des choses comme ça
parce qu'on sait pas du tout pas du tout
et la légalisation n'est pas la
libéralisation marc valleur psychiatre
est ce que vous devez répondre à cette
question le cannabis peut augmenter le
nombre de maladies psychiatriques est ce
que oui ou non le cannabis non enclenché
il faut y avait des trains pour les
parents qui regarde s'il faut une
réponse est oui ou non la réponse serait
non c'est pas il ya ce qu'on peut faire
des discussions d'experts très
compliquée sur le sujet il ya une
corrélation qui est de plus en plus
démontré entre schizophrénie et usages
des coûts de cannabis par contre les ya
une corrélation est ce que j'ai dit il
ya les causalités sont extrêmement
discuter et l'idée que le cannabis
fabrique de la schizophrénie est
combattue par la plupart des
spécialistes pharmacologue
la concentration des problèmes aux
scolaires à ce que oui ou non il ya un
lien bien évidemment bien évidemment
aussi ici l'automobile quand on a très
peu fait peu non très près pas le dire
je
alors là je vais pas y accéder à partir
de quand les questions
j'avais des champs solaires bien
évidemment le cannabis perturbe la
tension et il ya une étude qui montre
qui peut perturber les fonctions
cognitives au long cours chez des jeunes
qui l'utilisent très très tôt est à
partir de l'âge de 15 ans d'une manière
extrêmement intensive pendant plus d'une
dizaine d'années
bien évidemment c'est très dangereux de
consommer du cannabis est extrêmement
tôt on sait que le cerveau des enfants
est très vulnérable les abandons
l'entente de votre briquet et qu'il faut
les protéger bien évident on sait aussi
que l' usage intensif où l'on court ça
perturbe saran pêche des acquisitions et
autres de contrôler il faut évidemment
contrôler de même qu'il faut contrôler
le jeu de même qu'il faut contrôler
l'alcool qu'il faudrait contrôler le
tabac etc
il est bien évident que chez un enfant
l'usagé d'alcool précoce est encore plus
dangereux pour le cerveau c'est une
catastrophe au cerveau l'alcool est
légal mais j'espère que vous lui
interdisez à votre alors oui le monde a
donc savouré trop bien mais dès lors que
ce gros de la cigarette des enseignants
nous respectons saison être regardé
devant n'importe quel collège la
consommation massive juste moyen mot kim
qui me paraît essentiel dans cette
discussion c'est le mot de pragmatisme
et que quand l'on dit que la répression
n'est pas faite de manière pragmatique
en garde cent trente mille personnes
arrêtées chaque année pour consommation
de cannabis donc si on prend dix ans a
fait un million trois cent mille
personnes et 0 effet et 0 est fait pour
sur la baisse de consommation d'une
manière pragmatique il faut regarder ça
pour qu'ils aient un effet sanitaire et
je pense que les centres d'accueil et
d'accompagnement à la réduction des
usages de drogues que l'on propose aussi
dans cette dans ce dispositif est à même
de répondre à ces problèmes parce qu'il
y en a bien sûr ne les nie pas mais il
faut les traiter de façon pragmatique
martin perez
dans votre projet de loi vous expliquer
un certain nombre de conditions qui
seraient nécessaires pour se procurer du
cannabis
c'est à dire avoir au moins 18 ans si
j'ai bien compris et que ces textes a
aujourd'hui la consommation de cannabis
elle commence à 12 ans elle commence à
l'école elle commence au lisez et on
voit bien que pour le tabac
il ya même si la consommation de tabac
il ya une liste une limite d'âge pour
commencer
et bien cela n'est pas du tout respecté
je vois pas comment cette loi vous
pourrez faire respecter les limites
d'âge et empêcher les marchés parallèles
de continuer à exister
d'autant plus qu'il ya des gens qui sont
très friands de cannabis plus de doses
et en thc etc etc et donc je suis même
pas sûr que votre proposition de loi qui
vise à encadrer la consommation elle ne
soit pas uniquement destinés à des
personnes des adultes qui ont une
manière récréative de consommer du
cannabis pour qui ces quelques jeux pour
wii les exemples que l'on a cité tendent
à montrer que ce genre de mesure est
efficace justement pour allah ya un
sujet qui semble faire davantage
consensus et usage du cannabis à des
fins thérapeutiques il ya quelques jours
un débat sans vote s'est tenu au sénat
françois grosdidier
globalement la majorité des élus étaient
pour selon la dernière enquête de
l'observatoire français des drogues et
toxicomanies plus de neuf français sur
dix se disent favorables à
l'autorisation du cannabis thérapeutique
pour traiter certaines maladies et enfin
début avril c'est premier ministre
lui-même edouard philippe qui a ouvert
la voie il était en déplacement dans la
creuse ont écouté je vous fait réagir
après on utilise dans la fabrication de
médicaments des molécules qui sont des
molécules qui sont les mêmes que celles
qui constituent l'opium notamment en
tant qu évidemment on doit pouvoir
réfléchir à innover à expérimenter en le
faisant de façon très encadrée il ne
s'agit pas du tout de mettre en péril la
santé publique s'agit au contraire
d'utiliser ce que l'on sait pouvoir
utiliser ce que l'on veut pouvoir
utiliser pour apporter un bénéfice
thérapeutique aux patients il ya
beaucoup de pays qui travaillent là
dessus il ya beaucoup de pays qui le
permettent
il serait absurde de ne pas se poser la
question et c'est dans cet esprit que
nous voulons travailler avec les
porteurs du projet françois grosdidier
là c'est oui pour les canadiens mais
tout à fait je suis depuis très
longtemps et je regrette justement qu'on
puisse avoir cette confusion aujourd'hui
en lançant le débat relatif c'est très
clair bien
sur mes mais c'était vite chantier mais
pas du tout autrement n'est pas
interdire plein plein de bedie kébé
dicaments aujourd'hui sur le marché
et d'ailleurs il ya énormément de
molécules le support dans les
médicaments qu'ils sont très dangereuses
si on aussi si on les consomme sans
mesure où c'est pas justifiée par un
effet thérapeutique dont les débats sont
complètement distincts et se savait
partie taboue de cette société je trouve
absurde que pour de nombreux malades et
sclérose en plaques et bien d'autres je
dire on n'est pas depuis longtemps
autorisait le cannabis thérapeutique
mavala oui ça c'est une évidence et là
en plus des propriétés que peu de
médicaments au niveau rexie gêne ils
vont t'ils au mythique et surtout dans
le traitement de certaines douleurs qui
sont résistantes aux opiacés et aux
autres traitements donc le le cannabis
thérapeutique ça devrait être une
évidence et peut-être même le cannabis
est un petit pas seulement les molécules
exclu cannabis les pharmacologues aime
bien les produits plus là devrait être
une évidence dit de jouer ça ne l'est
pas pourquoi cette fête là aussi en
france pour le moment d'après vous on ne
dispose pas de cannabis thérapeutique
dans beaucoup de pays c'est essayer
d'égaliser
il faut remarquer que la plupart des
états américains qui ont légalisé le
cannabis récréatif avait d'abord égalisé
quelques confusions
oui alors c'est assez compliqué le
cannabis thérapeutique d'abord parce
qu'elle pas eu énormément d'études avec
des molécules du mans commercialisé pour
évaluer ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
attendre du cannabis thérapeutique
donc aujourd'hui c'est pas évident il ya
laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui en
france que le projet de mettre à me dire
on savait le sativex sur le marché le
problème c'est qu'ils réclament beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent pour le remboursement
par l'assurance maladie et qu'il ya un
débat là-dessus
par ailleurs les médecins sont pas du
tout préparés à la presse rémy à une
enquête récente qui a été fait dans les
pays européens
les médecins ne savent pas à quoi ça
sert ils savent pas comment ça va se
prescrire ils savent pas comment
l'encadrer savent pas quels lots savent
pas à quelle dose
donc je pense que on aurait quand même
besoin d'avoir des publications comme
bon feu comme on fait toujours dans la
science avait avec des preuves pour dire
voilà comment ça va être utilisé alors
des fois on a l'impression qu'on sort un
mot magique cannabis thérapeutique ça va
régler toutes sortes de problèmes
c'est pas aussi évident et nous aussi
simple que l'accueil réservé ou en tant
que médecin non j'ai pas de réseau
j'attends juste qu'on me dise oui dans
la sclérose en plaques ça permet
d'entendre % de cas d'empêcher les
douleurs liées à une à des spasmes
musculaires etc etc c'est pas moi qui
ait des réserves c'est que j'ai essayé
j'ai fait quelques chroniques sur le
sujet récemment j'ai essayé de lire tout
ce qui était publié là dessus et les
données scientifiques sont pas encore
suffisamment étayée pour dire oui il
faut se lancer là dedans
oui j'aurais aimé qu'ils aient eu les
mêmes réticences pour tous les
psychotropes chimiques qui envahissent
nos vies et nos pharmacies et j'ai les
mêmes réticences voilà donc pour moi
c'est pour ça que je trouve que c'est un
bon départ si on dit voilà ce cannabis
thérapeutique on le légalise on lan
cadre justement pour pour avoir une
mesure des effets de des conditions
d'utilisation des bénéfices que ça peut
apporter en forme en même temps
effectivement les praticiens à
l'utilisation de cette de cette nouvelle
possibilité
et voilà c'est là c'est la même logique
en fait c'est le pragmatisme on regarde
les études scientifiques je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous même si
j'ai pas votre niveau d'expertisé
il me semble que au niveau international
et quand même aujourd'hui assez de recul
pour dire que les effets positifs sont
sont avérées documenté donc moi je me
pense que c est ça serait quand même le
minimum qu'on démarre par là mais il
faudra aller plus loin alors edouard
philippe a fait cette déclaration dans
la creuse ça ne vous a pas échappé ce
n'est pas anodin le département attend
même que la cravate en de même cela avec
impatience
ce serait une vraie manne financière
pour les agriculteurs juste je vous cite
jouanny chatoux car l'agriculteur du
coin le thérapeutique ça va être très
encadré très compliqué très technique
donc ça concernera peu de personnes le
cannabis bien-être dit il
en revanche ce serait une vraie
opportunité pour nos agriculteurs en
creuse parce qu'on a des territoires
adapté aux chambres alors là expliquez
moi il fait une distinction entre
cannabis thérapeutique et cannabis
bien-être lorsque je peux dire c'est par
exemple dans des pays comme le canada
les médecins prescrivent du cannabis il
ya des magasins qui ont pignon sur rue
dans lesquels ils peuvent acheter du
cannabis prescrits par les médecins
c'est pas des médicaments de du du monde
manufacturés donc il ya plusieurs
manières de confort je sais pas
exactement comment entrer je sais que il
ya plusieurs manières de prescrire du
cannabis et pas seulement des
médicaments manufacturés en france
le plus souvent ça a été une démarche
compassionnel on n'est pas dans le cas
de lancement d'adobe de médicaments
d'une molécule qu'on ne connaîtrait pas
on a 17 millions d' expérimentateurs en
france est cliniquement ce qu'on voit
c'est des personnes qui ont utilisé du
cannabis qui utilisent parfois
régulièrement du cannabis et qui disent
ça me fait du bien c'est la seule chose
qui calme et douleur ça me fait du bien
c'est la seule chose qui me permet de
manger etc
c'est pour ça qu'on défend le cannabis
était un petit et consoles avec l'alcool
aussi et on va s'arrêter là sur ces mots
françois grosdidier merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé